SCOTTY
JARED McCANN!
WHO SHOWED A TONOVER, SUTER.
McCANN GETS DENIED,
DRIEDGER READY FOR THAT ONE. OP
OF THE
CORNER.
DONSKOI SUPPORTS IT, WILL WIND
IT OUT.
DUNN, INDIRECT PASS FINDING
McCANN, DONSKOI FOR PUCK DOWN,
YOU'LL TAKE THE ICING.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE IN.
GEEKIE HOUNDED BY MIRO
HEISKANEN,
ADAM LARSSON WIDE OF JOHN
KLINGBERG, OFF KLINGBERG, OFFNA.
A SHOT, STOPPED BY DRIEDGER,
REBOUND, AND DRIEDGER STICK GETN
AS HE
KLINGBERG DENIED, SHEAHAN, LAYS
IT OUT, HERE COMES TO GET THE P.
NICE PLAY TO THE FRONT OF THER
THIS WAY, HEISKANEN, WRIST PASS
TO THE CORNER, PLAYED BY
ONES THAT HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
A.
PAVELSKI, G G AT PAVELSKI GETTI
WITH DUNN, THROUGH CENTER, CUT .
YOU MAKE A MISTAKE IN THE
NEUTRAL ZONE, GURIANOV FINDSOLE
OUT IN FRONT, OETTINGER GLENDEN
GOOD OPPORTUNITY, IT IN.
WHAT A MOVE BY DONATO, GREAT
PASS FROM IN FRONT,
DRIEDGER A DANDY FOR
THE DEFENSEMEN, SAFETY MEASURE.
DON'T WANT TO GO INTO THE BOAO !
JOHN KLINGBERG GOES
QUICK, TRAFFIC IN FRONT.
BUT AGAIN, WHEN YOU WALK THE
T.
3:25
HEY,
BLOCKER, OVER THE   TRACK IT DO,